so the prosecution spent most of the
written house trial undermining its own
case and its closing arguments today was
no different than that how badly did it
go we'll take a look at this picture at
one point the prosecutor pointed an
ar-15 directly at jurors with his finger
on the trigger which news flash you're
not supposed to do keep your finger off
the trigger son
by contrast the closing argument from
the defense while not perfect went a
little more smoothly the defense
attorney mark richards chose his words
very carefully he explained that kyle
rittenhouse has a right not to be quote
molested
by joseph rosenbaum
he has as much right to go there as
anybody else in the city of kenosha and
beyond molested by the likes of joseph
rosenbaum
kelly and joshua zaminski
jonathan truly is professor at george
washington university law school he
joins us today having watched the trial
professor thanks so much for coming on
so i've got a million questions don't
have time for many here's the first so
we learned today that actually it's
legal in the state of wisconsin for a 17
year old to have a long gone
as rittenhouse did why did we not find
that out to the last day of the trial
this charge stood until today
that's an excellent question i wrote a
column
that actually questioned why this count
was allowed into the trial i'm baffled
how the prosecutors got an indictment on
this count uh
from my view
this has no applicability to the case
the this was not a short barreled weapon
you can determine that a simple
measurement and then the other
alternative conditions are not met by
him and so i'm not sure what the
prosecutors
said they got the indictment but the
court eventually did throw that out but
part of the problem here is that an oral
you know an opening statement is like an
oral contract with a jury they take it
very seriously when you say you're going
to show something they expect you to
show it when you say that you know
rittenhouse chased down rose and bloom
and shot them in the back they expect to
see it and in fact they didn't and in
fact they saw a one count drop and a
number of the assertions made in the
opening statement were gone by the
closing argument
so there was this super weird moment i
honestly don't know what to make of it
where the prosecutor today in his
closing remarks said look you know this
joseph roosevelt didn't really do
anything i mean he set some fires yeah
he moved obstructions in the road yeah
he screamed the n-word
why would the prosecutor remind the jury
the guy was setting fires and streaming
racial slurs i don't get it
yeah the prosecution could not be
working harder for acquittal i mean you
have a jury from kenosha and you're
mocking the notion that oh they set a
few fires
you know they they rioted a little
during questioning bingor said
made fun of the fact that they were
throwing
bricks at police cruisers and saying
that didn't really hurt those cruisers
did they and you can only imagine what
it's like to be a kenosha juror sitting
there and saying
whose counsel are you who are you
representing here
kenosha is already a forgotten town that
will never never be rebuilt i mean if
you live there this is not a small thing
we just i have to ask you hate to put
you on the spot what do you think is
going to happen with this jury
well i think the prosecution has reduced
the range of possibilities very likely
between a hung jury and outright
acquittal
you know the problem is you make
yourself an issue that's what the what
binger has done
he has contradicted his statements so
often presented evidence
that was not borne out
he's really begging for reaction from
this jury
but i would be very surprised if they
could eke out a single conviction on
this rather appalling record
yeah as a non-lawyer that's certainly
the way it seems to me so it's nice to
have that that instinct confirmed
professor thanks so much jonathan turley
with us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else